they might to mystify anyone fat getting
out of speak class
[Applause]
that jab step you got to step back
that's three straight offensive rebounds
and refuse by the day closing seconds
down to a half a second win Carmelo
Anthony let that one go you can't see
the Sun dari piano Florida ceiling with
Anthony he's money
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of credit he has been electric in
terms of the energy here by the ways as
a career-high five steel studs
Anthony
[Applause]
tt
just telegraphing there passes Ellis
with a good man down the block
we brought it up very nice one would
have had an open look if you short
between the middle of them nobody gets
one mellow at the buzzer
Carmelo accident count the basket swear
see live music applause and try and get
hold much to bring in the new year with
the little ones answered it Bargnani
and to those that bounce I'll say you
did
yeah well Carmelo has ten
[Applause]
loosen it can be abusive - like the
Westbrook if you allowing the
penetrating
anthony joseph smith first half
[Applause]
this is how they've got to play the rest
of the season where Zynga snapped it
away and a timeout budenholzer does not
like the look of his team on the floor
wins regular season their first NBA
championship since 1975 the Anthony
drives and finishes against Robert
Anthony quick spitless gets inside and
finishes regressive powerful from
Carmelo Anthony Lou Thesz on in and
through the jab step
9:07 baby wallow looking it's inside
keeps his dribble towards it out the
Lopez Anthony Anthony
it's a long time back Anthony Anthony
puts it up
[Applause]
jinsol acicular man go away
shot clock winding down locos finds
handsome
now at 21 Stan Lane running shot again
to storm off the glass yet that he gets
it back has to put it out
but he knocks it down Sefolosha has done
an excellent job on Anthony Anthony now
drives gets inside sit down gonna try
the three-point attempt
fires a trail
and off turnovers hosting up Kailah let
me straight we've seen him do that cat
was Todd's that's the set steel for the
Knicks
that's a three Sonny Weems
[Applause]
erotic carefully
Xterra t utilize it in the pan model
seconds here comes Anthony it's going to
the buzzer what a first quarter for
Carmelo Anthony he goes five of six on
the smash stuff like the rookie mario
hezonia jason smith the way that sun
presses it and I've never known three
guys like a different team to be the
most category Anthony nice Drive and
finished three-ball he's having a
mediocre season banking turnaround
difficult juggling gets you to go here
in the first half
Lowry baseline comes out the other side
[Applause]
will absolutely throw a lot of us family
students in the work this afternoon
[Applause]
[Music]
the game of the garden used to root for
the Knicks rejection out of balance a
loop right there the game in fact the
rolling down three after the first
quarter after that horrible start no one
inside there's a minute twenty nine
remaining in the second quarter Topher
to Anthony's another one the look at it
ruled the two on the floor man that's
three straight buckets for Carmelo
Anthony mismatch Melo has it tough
matchup with d'marie Carroll on the
bench Powell gets of course a kiss
speed from Anthony raptures do not have
a foul to give
[Applause]
Anthony shoots at scores at the buzzer
Carmelo Anthony wraps up a terrific
first half and Gomes was open and
Anthony mr. Anthony now takes a
contested shot back Saturday after
Russell Carmelo Anthony though the
second greatest Nick of all time this
isn't Lee actually cueing associate head
coach
Anthony's dribbles that's a rookie go
man tip misses rebound out to Anthony
Anthony pull-up jumper
capping off a sensational opening
quarter for Anthony give or they don't
want to use it here Anthony trying to
clear out kidd-gilchrist on him Rose
comes back
Anthony backs in turns puts it up three
seconds remaining
this time he wants the right side he's
got Wiggins on him single coverage
anthony face puts up the jumper puck
sitting with 2.3 relating pomelo it that
he nails it
and the Knicks lead by 2 Krenzel
deflected by rose we've also seen Rose
play some good solid defense ahead to
Anthony nicely advance pass and Anthony
the finished and that's the pace the
Knicks need to play tonight Rose finds
Anthony again Anthony here comes the
double-team shoot sovereign and connects
at the buzzer Carmelo Anthony struggling
shooting the ball well he moves without
the ball but he's open and he catches
and shoots
Anthony count it and a foul with white
Derrick Williams surname Thomas goes out
via bad Melo catches it puts it in
that's what I was alluding to he's gonna
has a very efficient at the timeouts
Harris where she could shoving Carmelo
that the ball stripped gets his back
puts up an off-balance shot
oh did a coupe whole subject of a
feature story Clyde it's Anthony slams
it down
[Applause]
seven is shoot
Anthony pulls up truth three Carmelo
Anthony gives them mix the Lee teams
have been resilient pets well believed
cities is already chopped clock winding
down as Anthony fires at hits do not
have a foul to give here
Anthony catches one dribble fires at ray
[Applause]
Anthony from downtown
we take a one-point lead into the locker
room box do not have a foul to give
Anthony spins falling away it's good the
puzzle
second time is rate set by porzingis
porzingis lost his left sneaker as fa
hits another three that's his fourth
clever slick getting to the heat
Anthony launches another and hits
another red-hot to start last two you
could question the shot selection
thinning Millsaps on him six seconds
drives inside there was no he got hit
man he typed the ball came up with two
point six
he wrote Anthony that Hardaway on a man
Anthony lost his head bang on the
baseline and he got another one
a delivers the deuce and were tied again
clock turned off the bridge could not
have a foul to give
Anthony drives draws the foul
[Applause]
muche right on top of Obon Anthony with
a veteran play hey little knock it down
Knicks players meanwhile they're trying
to ignore all the outside noise as much
as they can but even their head coach
Jeff hornacek said his players say the
right things Carmelo Anthony finishes on
the break early in the morning for one
of his workouts after one of his rough
games as Anthony got hit and finishes
plus the foul and Melo cannot be stopped
in his first quarter covington three
seconds Carmelo shoot
[Applause]
Malus Jefferson Gardens hello Anthony
pump fake
you mentioned it as Carmelo Anthony
Clyde the other night the old Quinn's
got to stay with Lopez now he can't drop
off white head turns it over
good job by lead lead pull-up jumper got
it beeps a weapon in the game has ever
seen yeah 38,000 career fires like
Meritage to fall down on crossover and
the next back up by 21 nancy has otto
porter waterers had a good season and
these jumpers go like that composed in
that time by mellow still great Kuzmich
cos now let's entry post
[Applause]
no matter where
gets it on exit Carmelo Anthony had his
back to the basket when a last-minute
turn seven shooting
[Applause]
I agree with you low pass from Anthony
Adams Road to the basket Pittman Carmela
with a tremendous recovery Indiana
shooting 9 of 20 cool
[Applause]
Anthony terrific abortion the screen
from Adam Japanese floral assistant
patients on offense
Anthony of greenish Paterson
infringement under and one for Melo
that's good job just you know selling
that moon George Robertson and Adams
starting five back in now throw species
beautiful pass boy
thread the needle they're perfect bounce
pass at Adams completes sends Westbrook
on his way Grizzlies has missed their
last five shots
here's that catching through shoot three
four anthony scores that's exactly what
we're talking about Roberson is on the
floor Evans
[Applause]
something Thunder scoring run that had
reached eight points over the top
Anthony to Westbrook
and some pretty basketball right there
losing stages in the victory over hust
is the other night with the deflection
there where a person was absolutely aces
has been in the early going a little bit
mellow and the law as a start and all
fall off the bench so if they don't see
a place for him here he can help a lot
of different teams for their couple
realizing they can they can unload them
if they have to there Clarkson you get
14 15 points per season clutter drive by
Westbrook officials but but this got a
chance to establish a tutor section lead
mellow eyed advantage against JR Smith
oh what a move by Carmelo Anthony how
many times have we seen that welcomed by
knots he could do it on either side
after he found out he was traded he has
been putting on weight to play the bases
and do a lot of things for them as Melo
hits down the stair down 3 only 1 of 9
from three atoms with the block on
Gortat here fourth block of the ball
games for Oklahoma City Anthony is gonna
die he's gonna back it and he's got to
go to the free-throw line and without
fouling
[Applause]
[Music]
Anthony catches nuts at different page
makes of paper Greg and PG out around
the 3-minute mark have them French to
start period to six to shoot
Rubio the bounce Gobert turns it over
[Applause]
goes airborne